hi adam and rich this is john calling
from
the north of england um so i learned to
swim
three years ago um and this summer i'm
doing a swim run
that has lakes and um trail running and
it has a lake crossing in it um
i don't have any access to lakes to
train in because they become too
polluted
in my neck of the woods um but i do have
access to the sea
and obviously it can be really rough or
it can be cold so
it's kind of warmed up to about 44 45
fahrenheit now
but i can't do huge distances because i
just get really really cold
and if it's too rough then i just get
beaten up and i again can't do huge
distances
so i also have access to a swimming pool
and i'm just wondering
how would you kind of um navigate those
two options
thanks very much bye john coming in hot
with the vegan swim run question
my favorite kind of question yes and
with the great accent right out of the
north
the north and the game of thrones how
far north and it's
the north this is john the north wait is
john from the north yeah
like jon snow is this jon snow
jon snow's not in first of all jon snow
just learned to swim that's to me that
the best part of this question is he
just learned to swim three years ago
right and he's in a swim run
i love it that's amazing i love that you
want to take a stab at this answer first
well i'll let you talk about the best
way to train since i just kind of wing
it
but um i mean with apologies to nicholas
who i don't wing it i i do as i'm told
but i do also
wing it to some degree um the one thing
i would recommend because of your ocean
like for me personally i like to swim in
the ocean i don't swim in pools
um but uh since you're new to swimming i
would guess like a lot of even
triathletes that are very good in pools
they'd often the transition to getting
into open water is
a little bit rougher they're not that
great or comfortable let's just say
they're not as comfortable in open water
and there is a comfort level of swimming
in open water that
that you won't have in the although
there will be wind in a lake and there
might be waves it won't be the same
thing as a rough shot
and so um if you're going to go into the
sea and there's not a lifeguard on duty
and you're swimming alone
i'd be very cautious at first if you're
not comfortable with it
um i would try to swim in tandem at
least
in the open water especially at those
temperatures that's dangerous
and um it can be dangerous if you're not
in the right wetsuit
and so i think that those things you
know in hawaii there's a phrase they
have on almost every beach
when in doubt don't go out and i think
it's okay to feel some butterflies but i
don't think it's okay
to put yourself in a dangerous dangerous
situation so
um i do think you need to be mindful of
conditions and temperature
if you're going to be alone and so
that's the only thing i would say about
the ocean
adam dropping open water safety
knowledge yes like a true
lifeguard yeah true watermen yeah no
yeah so here's here's what i think um
i think you're gonna be fine john uh
kudos for
tackling a swim run three years into
learning how to swim i think that's
ballsy and amazing
if it makes you feel any better i
trained almost entirely for
the attila swim run world championships
in a swimming pool i almost never went
in open water now
that being said i have a lot of open
water experience so i i didn't feel like
the need to get comfortable in open
water
so what i would say to you is double
down on the swimming pool
use that as much as possible to develop
your fitness and your endurance and your
strength
um and you can also use the pool for in
and out you know swim run transitions
right so in and out swim
swim run swim run swim run get used to
swimming and running and if you can if
they'll let you at your pool
swim in the pool with your wetsuit on
and your shoes on because swimming with
tennis shoes is a very strange
it is sensation uh that you're gonna
have to acclimate to
and if you can if the if the pool will
allow you to do it i would suggest
doing that as much as possible and of
course using the hand paddles and
getting used to all the gear and all of
that is really important
but i would say that
the pool is sub-optimal you always want
to be kind of out in the natural
environment
in terrain that's going to mimic the
actual race course and that isn't quite
available to you
so what i would suggest is you avail
yourself
of the sea but just pick your moments
like once a week
or when the the the conditions are
are you know fine like it's not i
wouldn't go out when it's
crazy choppy or anything like that and
also 44 45 degrees is no joke so
make sure you're wearing an appropriate
wetsuit for that kind of weather
um and five millimeters yeah get out get
out in the in the
in the sea um and you could do short
swim work swim run workouts where you're
just you swim 200
meters and then run up the shore and you
know run for a half mile and go and then
run back into the
sea so you're not really in the ocean
that long but you're getting used to
you're acclimating
not only to what it feels like to be in
open water
but also the weirdness and discomfort of
running up the shore and running back in
like developing a comfort level with all
of that
from a mental and emotional perspective
i think is huge
because if you can handle that these
lakes are going to be
so easy right there will be no
intimidation because you've been out
battling freezing water
um in in the sea the lakes of course are
not going to have
salt water so there's a different kind
of buoyancy thing
yeah you're not going to be as buoyant
like there's something when you swim in
the ocean
you ride very high in the water and it
actually makes it easier to swim
yeah if it's calm so the lake you're
going to you're going to ride a little
bit lower
and you'll feel a little bit more like
you're fighting the water than you would
in the ocean
but i think you're actually in a great
situation to
be mentally prepared because of
the conditions in in which you live so
pick your moments
the lakes will be easy after those north
sea excursions
and i don't know what the the land
terrain is
around you and i don't know what the
terrain of this
specific swim run course looks like but
i would
if i made one mistake and i've said this
before on the podcast in training for
sweden
you know i was just running trails and
and kind of gradual climbs and things
like that and the the course in sweden
was very technical it was very rocky
there was a lot of client there was
there actually wasn't that much running
it was a lot of trudging and climbing up
rocks and things like that
so get really familiar with the terrain
of the race
and try to find terrain in your natural
environment near your home
where you can mimic what it's going to
be like during the race
yeah i mean for me saying don't go out
alone i mean i
i do go out and swimming alone but the
temperatures are different but um
i will say uh i was gonna ask you rich
what do you think about
like since it's a lake that he hasn't
been in like how you went to
um the sierras to train at altitude and
swam in tahoe
um would you recommend maybe if you have
time and you have
the the the time inclination maybe a
a week excursion or even just a weekend
to a lake that you do feel comfortable
swimming in that would be
the ability in the time yeah you could
drive to some lake that maybe is not
that far away yeah just just for the day
or for the weekend or something like
that and get used to
you know experiencing what it's like to
swim in a lake i think that
he hasn't done that that'd be good don't
you think yeah yeah
but i promise you if you get comfortable
swimming
in the north in the north sea uh you're
going to be fine in the lake
yeah you might want to get a seven mil
wetsuit for
swimming and it would be you know uh
unless you're unless you're doing swim
run in that case
just get a thick the thickest swim
runway so you can get for that
[Music]
[Music]
you